the jurogan experience if dana said that
that makachev now has to fight benil
daryush before he could fight for the
title i think that sets up a conor fight
i think that might be white but that's
probably why that's probably honest
because connor was at bellator last
friday and he did an interview and he
said yeah i think i'm coming back and
fighting for the belt
and that's kind of crazy oh no it's it's
wild but but
if you want the company
would you want that to happen you
probably would let's be honest because
the reality is conor's best days have
long gone they're behind him you know
you can't stay at the top perhaps
probably probably the last fight listen
we got to look at it this way it takes a
long time off the cowboy fight is very
quick you don't get to see what's really
going on and then
dustin [ __ ] him up and dustin [ __ ]
him up with calf kicks his leg was
destroyed that's one of the best
examples of a calf kick winning the
fight and then of course beautiful
combination starts off with that right
hand rocks him puts him away knocks him
out no questions asked then it comes in
the second fight with a hairline
fracture already in his shin yeah and
then fights and his his leg snaps he
falls back it's very
it's very
unsatisfying it is unsatisfying and then
he has a year off yeah and then also who
knows what he's like now i mean his
[ __ ] shin has a bolt in it forever
he's got these plates on his shin trying
to
glue the whole thing together and it's a
year later a year out of his problem i
mean who knows she hasn't spoiled i'll
tell you this though if there's a person
that you put him against in the top five
to beat
it would be charles oliveira you think
so charles is hittable
and conor can still [ __ ] hit that's
true fast you know charles
is hittable he's edible but he could
take it too man he's not going to rest
on he can't take he can take it man
the fact that he survived both dustin's
onslaught where he really was going to
get put away and justin uh uh
michael chan
chandler had him hurt bad yeah you know
survives that and then comes out and
starches chandler in the second round
yeah but he's not superman
he's not superman but god does not
understand like who else is that i'm
engaging okay he never uses his bloody
wrestling anyway
who knows is that islam wouldn't be good
who else is there chandler would
probably wrestle him so in terms of
stylistic match-up gage is very
dangerous for a guy like connor if conor
if if gaichi beats oliveira
gaiji versus connor is a dangerous fight
for conical who the [ __ ] kicks your legs
better than gage oh [ __ ] i've never
thought of that i thought you're talking
about this boxing it's boxing's
ferocious yeah no no i forgot you're
right though the car kicks the leg cakes
his leg kicks
some of the best in the game and he also
is a great wrestler too of course and
gaechi will kick your leg from inside a
tie up which is crazy you ever see him
do that his hips are so flexible yeah he
could throw those tight leg kicks from
like grabbing inside he's got like an
over under on you and he [ __ ] kicks
your legs yeah yeah no it's crazy his
highlight reel like is some of the best
leg kicking i've ever seen in the
lightweight division it's [ __ ]
amazing and he did it to guys like edson
barbosa like lights his legs up i'm just
saying though there's a potential that
connor comes back beats charles oliver
and becomes champion again because that
is and then that's
i don't think i can deal with the world
is
oh my god oh my god ireland would have a
[ __ ] parade that would last a month
long but it might happen it might be
listen if conor connects on anybody's
mug that's what i'm saying you never
know he's still got that left hand he's
still got power and speed for us farasa
hobby calls the touch of death is that
what he calls for us to hobby yeah he's
got the touch of death
does he does diminished a little bit
because
well you know again it's like it's one
of the things that he said about the
first poirier knock when cor pory
stopped him he goes it was too much
inactivity i wasn't you know i'm not
ready for this yet yeah then he comes
back fights him a second time and the
second time gets [ __ ] up and with a
broken leg so it's like i don't know
you know where he's at now mentally but
he's got so much [ __ ] money yeah he
sold proper 12. he made like a half a
billy yeah
that's it though it changes i mean you
can say whatever you want of course he's
gonna say that and
we all say it you know oh i'm still the
same guy i'm still the same fighter no
you [ __ ] ain't right no you're not
your motivation for doing this
is gone right you're doing it now
because listen and you've got to respect
this about him we don't have a good
relationship but got to respect this
about it he loves the fight game you
know what i mean and i respect that
about him i really do so that's
something that's the only thing that he
can't buy right i mean the guy can buy
whatever he wants right right right he's
buying yachts and this and that god
bless him but you can't buy the ufc
championship of the world that's the
only thing he can't buy so he's got no
choice to go and fight for it and he's
still choosing to do that you have to
respect that to be honest